a few weeks ago I went to the opening of
King Abdullah's new University is called
cows King Abdullah University of Science
and Technology and it's supposed to
rival MIT it's supposed to be an Arab
MIT Massachusetts Institute of
Technology it already has the second
largest endowment of any university in
the world second only to Harvard they're
trying to bring and have already brought
some of the world's great scientific
researchers mathematicians not just to
teach there but to do research and bring
students from all around the world you
can only go there if you're a graduate
student and in a way it was not like
being in Saudi Arabia there were young
men and women mingling on the campus
together now you never see that in Saudi
Arabia they have male campuses they have
female campuses if there happens to be a
male lecturer who lectures two women he
does it rather like this talking to a
camera with the women in a room looking
at him on a screen and when they want to
ask him a question they have to press a
buzzer most of us who were there felt
this is a tremendous step forward for
Saudi Arabia but next day the television
shows full of traditional old sheiks
complaining that the king was corrupting
the country by having men and women
mixing together on the campus
complaining that this university was
going to teach science no religion
whatsoever
Saudi Arabia one of the paradoxes of it
is and we see it with king abdullah king
after all is sort of like saudi arabia's
Obama he is the embodiment of hope he
doesn't always achieve what people hope
but he talks good talk he clearly
believes that he's trying to push Saudi
Arabia into the modern age and this
university is the one of the vehicles
for it
Saudi Arabia now does regard itself as a
major force for peace in the the big
issue of Israel and Palestine and I
would say they're right about that King
Abdullah straight after 9/11 went to
work to rally around the America the
Arab states and get them to agree to
what is known as the Arab Peace
Initiative which says which offers
Israel full normalization in return for
the return of Palestinian land as it was
formerly defined with fairly vague
language about what compensation and and
just settlement will will will be paid
to the Palestinian refugees now as we
and then having got this through the
Arab nations with some difficulty he
then convened an islamic conference in
2005 and got the whole Muslim world to
sign off but one of the weird things
about Saudi Arabia is that this older
generation of old and fairly fairly
enlightened men trying to push the
country forward he's not matched by the
mass of the population who are the
Islamists who are the guys who secretly
chair and not so secretly cheer for bin
Laden young Saudis young Arabs who
looked on television every day and see
their brother Muslims getting beaten up
by American troops now we know
historically why the American troops
have gone to Iraq and Afghanistan but
the Saudis just see the young Saudis in
particular see America as a nation
that's waging war on Muslims troops
getting trained for the purpose of
killing Muslims they hear about video
games in which Arabs and dark-skinned
people are the victims and they see kids
in America playing their video games
joining the army and putting it into
practice and in in Islamic countries so
one of the problems for the future in
Saudi Arabia is you can't say all these
extremists are Oh
people who are going to die away and the
enlightened young generation will take
over it's sort of the opposite you know
the the older generation they remember
all 30 years ago women used to be able
to water-ski in ordinary swimming
costumes now if you sometimes see women
waterskiing as a bizarre sight in a bias
black bias robes and things but there's
been this extraordinary regression in
western terms and westernized older
Saudis remember that with some regrets
so when people ask about the future of
this society who knows I mean King
Abdullah is a great believer in
knowledge he's taken that idea from the
West he's also taken it from the Islamic
past in the Islamic Golden Age
soon after the time of the Prophet when
learning let's not forget was kept alive
by the Muslims words that we've got like
algebra and logarithm all this
scientific knowledge with those
particular words come from Arabic roots
because it was Arabic scholars who kept
all that going they discovered the works
of Plato and so on and and preserved
them so that the West could rediscover
them later and so that the Golden Age of
Islam was an age of knowledge and and
King Abdullah he's trying to achieve
that he sees his new University as the
house of knowledge there was a famous
Bayt al-hikma a house of knowledge in
early Islamic times which you know the
the let's not forget the first
universities in the world were Alcazar
and other Arab universities and that's
the golden age that he is trying to
revive now what's going to happen when
these Saudi kids have been through all
these universities and there's no jobs
for them because that's the challenge
for Saudi Arabia is it's a one product
country and although it's trying to
diversify all the oil comes out of the
ground
that's another reason why there's not
going to be democracy in Saudi Arabia
for a long time because when your main
source of income your national resource
is controlled by the government and
there's no tax how do the people acquire
rights
traditionally in history we acquired our
rights America acquired its rights from
from Britain by saying no taxation
without representation
well Saudi Arabia is the most incredible
welfare state they're not worried about
socialized medicine they get free health
care they get free education when
students get to university they get a
scholarship a monthly pay packet to pay
their expenses no fees now all of this
comes from the oil it's a huge welfare
state so and the government controls it
the government controls that patronage
and there's not many jobs associated
with oil so all these bright young
graduates what are they going to do for
jobs